the gyro can experience comedy and magic
together is a weird combination when
they have those shows at the comedy
magic club they'll have a magician do 15
then you do stand-up afterwards it's
real weird it does it back but it's and
people enjoy it it's like a cool variety
thing down I could do it I've seen guys
the magician guys like they don't get to
go up so you're just going around the
parties just like right just like
flipping cards right there [ __ ]
will suck all the women out of a [ __ ]
room with trickery oh my god yeah why do
women like that kind of trickery they
just want to be I don't know they just
want to feel like oh they want to see
some sorcery yes some type of sorcery do
they whenever they go it's all you see
like fairy tales are real and that's
when you start [ __ ] start disappearing
meaning I've been in [ __ ] David
Blaine [ __ ] took my watch off before
really yeah he do some crazy how they
take your watch off I don't know man he
just did it some David Blaine [ __ ] that
makes me this [ __ ] regurgitating
some frogs before I just it just makes
me nervous that a guy would be so slick
he would actually be able to take your
watch off I know they exist
yeah people cook you did you said it it
happened to you I know other people have
said it happen to them he's done it
that's a game of them it's always a
negative team oh I just I believe it but
I've never seen it but I think there's
there's levels to everything if you give
you some elite world champion gold
medalist in the Olympics level of watch
picking you know I mean some dudes like
yeah like you've seen dudes do [ __ ] with
their hands when they move cards around
and it's [ __ ] confusing their hands
are so goddamn fast their dexterity when
they're moving the decks together and
doing that kind of [ __ ] I mean there's
some dudes have control of their hands
that's just off the charts and if
they're about picking watches they could
get you they can get you you just made
me what look for my watch I'm like you
just pick my [ __ ] have you ever been
pickpocketed I don't think so I don't
think so either
I've been robbed before but never been
pickpocketed I think it's like what's
this that's when he threw up the [ __ ]
frog oh where where was the frog in his
stomach
really
Frog dead that was alive what kind of
torture is that he swallowed three but
they stayed in there that's what's crazy
did it freaked everybody out in that
[ __ ] room bro that takes balls to
swallow a frog like what happens if that
thing has bacteria in it or some weird
disease and it breaks down in your gut
what if you don't throw it up in time
what if that [ __ ] don't come
back out
yeah he just until he run out of breath
like he just down it till he can't
breathe anymore
it's watch right there on the right
really he's white shaking his hands he
just did it but how did he do it
I mean see that again isn't 10 seconds
he's already jiggling it right now you
can see him [ __ ] with rooster and his
David Blaine he's [ __ ] with ya now
it's almost undone that's gone wow I was
paying attention to that dude
that is impressive the way he shook it
and it seems like he did some sort of a
magic trick with the cards too I'm sure
you might that's the part that's what
they're stunned by right yeah yeah it's
a mystery when people have that kind of
hand control stay the [ __ ] away from
them that's a dangerous person yeah what
do you have time to practice deception
at that level I don't want to get
anything from David Blaine that month
just look you just oh he gave it back
bro you're a Whitney Cummings bit about
magicians no she was they don't like
women liars that's why you never see
women magicians I was like oh [ __ ] she
said that was one of those when someone
says something you go oh [ __ ] find me a
[ __ ] woman magician there might be
like three of them ever I don't think
the woman's magicians Association of
America is now outraged I'm sure there's
some meet women magicians but you don't
know what see don't never I don't even
know any of them I don't know any of
them I know a bunch of male magicians
but maybe I'm a sexist piece of [ __ ]
yeah I don't understand how no woman has
broke them the magician all right
barrier I think magic as like a pen in
our form or David Blaine form I think
it's an incredible art form that's very
difficult for anybody and if it's not in
your culture right like if it's not
like a bunch of women magician guides
and you know mentors that could help you
figure it out and get it's probably
weird for them like who the [ __ ] why
they don't have time samples
why aren't there a lot of female
magicians people like magic shows right
that's right you ever go see Penn &
Teller it's great you haven't seen them
live it's a [ __ ] great show I believe
they're two professors I've been doing
it for a while shame or anything well I
think there's no female magicians how
many of them there are there let's guess
googled famous female ones that I have
never heard of any of the top five like
let me see what you got give me the top
five hi there we go
hey presto she's probably all right
never heard of you either [ __ ]
misty Lee um say that name Vince kai
ming kai ming kai ming kai maybe
Kristen Johnson Dorothea Dietrich
Dietrich Dietrich okay I don't know who
those people are either assistants I
don't know if there's some problem with
crossover Oh like maybe if you have your
assistant she's like super hot she's
like I want to magic to like baby I'm
the magician you're the assistant like
but I can [ __ ] do it I know how like
put baby after a while you know she's
hot and you're not and he's just trying
to keep her I think okay okay okay let's
try so you can do if you just taught me
with like a little more patience maybe I
could do exactly what you're doing but
you're afraid you're afraid that I'll be
better than you is that what this says
that's how she would be I picture her
with fiery red hair a tight waist but I
really never ever that's so crazy I've
never seen a female magician when
Whitney said that joke I was howling I
was like that's one of those ones we
like oh my god how come nobody ever
pointed that out before she caught it
she's ran with it
oh it's such a good point too that's why
we don't like women liars
because everybody has to go oh yeah oh
Jesus Christ what is it there aren't any
female magicians you know everybody's
have to go it's one of those things you
hear it you go [ __ ] she's right she is
right what has a job is there with us
like no females there's a this is a not
the reason why but this is an
interesting point so Cass this question
an article in 2013 and one person said
the reason that some kids get into magic
is because they got beat up oh I had to
find magic and that's what led them to
find making friends and like a lot of
girls don't not having that that makes
sense I'm telling you it's a gift you'll
get it it's a chick magnet right they
can that's a really I could really see
that as something - for a guy this is
what is this confidence this is what we
combine there's not a lot of money in
being like a fitness chick on Instagram
sticking your ass out the markets kind
of flooded but you could separate
yourself from the pack if you're a
fitness chick who does magic magic with
big tits and spandex come on kids
that could work that could work that
magic in like the most revealing
ridiculous yoga outfit oh yeah
bears raizy barefoot make it disappear
bending over for nutritionist Marc
Macklemore says he's a magician now
releasing magic rap album good for him I
heard the I like that guy good for him I
bet he could do it magic what can stop
some what maybe he loved magic already
what can stop someone from being a
magician that's one of those gigs were
like kind of anybody could do it well
yeah I mean not anybody could do it well
don't get me wrong it's a lot of skill
to it but I'm saying nothing's gonna
stop you from practicing you could get a
look you could take classes right you
could you could buy a kit right people
learn how to do magic nothing could stop
you
first-ever magic rap album interesting
what do you think that could mean
anything he wants it to mean he's crazy
you know you do maybe it's just to get
us to talk about it not us but you know
everybody I mean that's what it was
about
yeah it's good marketing move some
brilliant fella he nailed it we're all
at what that's the move you got to trick
people
days chickenstein just confuse them
[Applause]